[Music]
so apparently you didn't get the memo
why are you still around what part don't
you understand about shutting up David
well I never said I would and to be
honest with you I'm not afraid of
censorship anymore
we found a way to get our work out there
there is no way mainstream media can
bully us is that what you think one
phone call and I can get all your
content be monetized all of it how does
that sound
honestly it wouldn't be nice but we
would be okay well I guess I will make
that phone call
let's see how much longer the Pakman
show lasts all the revenue
dries up but that's just it it wouldn't
thanks to blockchain and steam the team
and I can focus on creating great
content without fearing censor what do
you need change speed what is this thing
well steam is a cryptocurrency that is
changing how social media and content
generates revenue online users and
content creators can interact and make
money without having to rely on a
centralized control basically what I'm
saying it's censorship proof do you mean
to tell me you can make money without us
you must be joking you expect me to
believe you I'm not only saying we can
continue to operate the Packman with
steam our viewers are followers can also
earn rewards simply by supporting our
show and yeah I do expect you to believe
that blockchain is here to stay and it's
changing this dynamic I already invited
my subscribers and followers to come
join me on Steam it and the growth of
the community has been fantastic you can
check it out yourself if you want this
must be some sort of trick you won't be
able to get away with this
you need us I think we already did hey
this is David from the David Pakman show
and I wanted to invite you our listeners
our viewers to join the team and I on
Steam it dot-com slash at david
hackman's
and participate with us on this
blockchain revolution that is not only a
platform that has allowed the David
Pakman show to flourish these hospitals
but has also helped many other content
creators and thinkers to get their
voices out there you can support us on
the platform and the best part is that
you can also earn rewards by supporting
your favorite time and I can't wait to
see you all there and share with you in
this great revolution
[Music]